okay let's do some audience questions
for the week some good ones I'm looking
forward to answering today first one is
from Sam hey David why does your show
have a mostly male audience well this is
actually it's not just our show this is
a general dynamic for shows like ours in
general and this is something I've
talked to a lot of people about I know a
Sam cedar and I have talked about this
and I've talked about it with a lot of
folks over at the young turks and it is
sort of a tough nut to crack and what it
really comes down to is that
fundamentally online news and politics
has a mostly male audience so it's not
so much about the show's it's about the
format I don't have a single close
female friend I can think of that
watches my show or shows like mine I
mean period they you know they're sort
of tangentially aware of my show because
they see stuff on Facebook for example
but nobody that I know who is is a woman
regularly says oh yeah I watched The
Young Turks or Sam cedar or whatever and
it is really common for shows like the
david pakman show to have anywhere from
60 to 80 percent male audiences I think
our podcast audience is has a little
more female to male ratio in it the
YouTube channel is more male than the
podcast for example hard to get data
from radio or from television and part
of it is the format which is it's just a
format that is more heavily watched by
men part of it is also story selection
because if you look at studies about
which stories were more followed by men
versus more followed by women when you
look at from Pew Research for example
the news stories that were more followed
by women than men it's all stories that
we didn't cover okay so the coal miners
in Utah was a news story that was
followed more by women than by men
contaminated pet food we didn't cover it
maybe it got a mention on the bonus show
the Chinese toy recall a variety of
kidnappings of kids that I don't even
remember at this point over the years
the story about drug-resistant staph
infections spreading we didn't cover or
barely covered any of those stories so
it's also story selection if you look at
stories like for example at Venezuela
the Supreme Court immigration Iran those
are stories that were more heavily
followed by men than by women so in
short you've got a format that in
general is more watched by Mendon by
women and then you have story selection
within our show which also seems to not
be including some of those stories that
were followed more close closely by
women and that's sort of where you end
up now I am NOT considering it sort of a
foregone conclusion or sort of fait
accompli we are actively talking about
how can we increase our female following
and you know there's little things that
I do
one is with voicemails when we get
voicemails from women I make sure to try
to get more of those voices represented
because it creates this vicious circle
if everybody you hear leaving a
voicemail is male and you're female that
might be a disincentive to even call in
so same thing with phone calls we've got
some great female callers including
valve from Agawam who we love and when
she calls then we just try to you know
include more female voices and also with
guest selection there is actually a big
discussion that happens in general when
doing analyses of news media that
they're not only is there a big
corporate skew of so-called experts on
news media there's also a major male
skew and so since overwhelmingly the
guests that we get pitched are men we
also make sure that for the guests that
we decide to go after and invite to the
show that we're including a mix and
we've had some really great female
guests as well so that's what we're
doing but there are some sort of
systemic issues that explain a lot of
why that is now if you say why is it
that online news and politics does not
appeal to women as much as it does to
men I don't have the answer and I'd be
curious to hear from you what you think
might explain it